- When I read the Freedom
of Information Act,
a judge ordered the
release of emails
of Fauci and these
virologists on January 31st.
So about 10:30 at night, Fauci
begins exchanging emails.
He exchanges them till
three in the morning.
You can tell by the
tenor that he's worried
and he's concerned, not
only about the origins,
but that the origins could
boomerang and come back
and that he could be exposed as
the one who approved
the funding.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today is a
senator from Kentucky and author
of the new book "Deception:
The Great COVID Coverup,"
Senator Rand Paul, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me,
Dave. Good to be with you.
- It's good to be with you.
Before we dive into
the book and COVID,
and I have a feeling you don't
really like this
Anthony Fauci fellow,
there is chaos in the House,
of course, you're in the Senate,
but what do you make of
this lunacy at the moment?
- Well, you know,
I'm sympathetic to
the argument that we
should do individual
spending bills,
that we should try
to use the power
of the purse to
bring down spending.
Just the last three months,
we've accumulated over a
trillion dollars in new debt.
We've never added a trillion
dollars in three months before,
so the spending
is out of control.
There is some blame
to go around. I mean,
there's no budget.
The Republicans pass
no budget in the House
and the Democrats pass
no budget in the Senate.
Neither party seems
to be too concerned
with what's going
on, so no budget,
and then the fiscal year
ends on September 30th.
They didn't pass any
appropriation bills, zero.
The House passed one, and now,
we're laboring over trying to
stick three or four together,
but it's utter incompetence
and it's been going on
for 40 years, you know?
It makes me tempted to wanna
vote for none of the above.
(Dave laughing)
(Rand scoffing)
- I was gonna say,
does it, like,
particularly a guy like you
who actually cares about math
and carrying the one and
making sure our bills are paid,
it's sort of gotta, like,
particularly stick in your craw,
but I guess you've
become accustomed to
this kind of thing.
- Well, it's kind of a false
debate too that we're having
because we're voting and
examining spending bills
that comprise 16% of the budget.
So two thirds of the
budget's entitlements
and they said, "Oh no.
We're afraid. We don't want
to reform the entitlements.
There's no money to save.
Two thirds of the budget,
we're not gonna look at,"
and then the remaining third
half of it's military,
and they said, "Oh,
we wanna give the military
an increase of 3%."
So entitlements
are going up at 5%,
military's going up at 3%,
and then they left
16% of the budget,
this is about $700
billion, and they said,
"Oh, we're gonna
try to hold the line
on this and maybe not
increase it that much,
or maybe spend what
we spent last year."
You could eliminate the budget,
the money we're looking at,
the non-military
discretionary spending,
and you still don't
balance a budget.
You'd still have an
$800 billion deficit
if you eliminated
all the spending
and none of them are talking
about eliminating it.
They're talking about, like,
a 1% cut on 16% of the budget.
So these people don't
recognize the severity
or the significance of
the debt problem we face.
- I think that's what
we call Swamp 101,
but we'll hold that conversation
to next time I have you on,
but let's talk about the book.
I love the cover, the fact that
you put Fauci on in a mask,
a guy, who I've been saying,
should really be hiding in
a cave at this point instead
of being on all
the Sunday shows,
which he's still on.
What do you think,
let's start just
briefly on Fauci
and then we'll get to
sort of the whole thing,
what do you think should
happen to Fauci at this point?
Like, do you actually
want him to be prosecuted?
I mean, I know he's not
running the NIH anymore,
but what do you think
should happen to him
if we're ever gonna get past
all the damage that was done?
- Well, you know,
we referred him twice to
the Department of Justice.
We haven't gotten
a lot of action.
We barely can even get a letter
back saying they've
received the referral,
but we sent him for
a criminal referral
for lying to Congress,
that is a felony,
and you face up to five
years in prison for that,
but above and beyond that,
and I think he deserves that,
he also deserves the
culpability basically
for funding the research
that became the pandemic,
and this is a big deal.
This is no small
mistake that he made.
It may be one of the
worst mistakes made
in modern history, or
in recorded history,
to fund a totalitarian
government that created a virus
that lept into humanity
and spread like wildfire
and killed millions
of people all
because Doctor Fauci's
opinion is that,
even if a pandemic were to
occur, gain of function,
this juicing up a virus's
research, is worth it,
and frankly, I think the
millions of Americans who died,
if you ask their families,
"Was it worth it,
the knowledge from gain
of function research,
was it worth it,"
I think you'd find that
most American families,
and frankly
(Rand sniffling)
worldwide, would
be upset, you know,
that this was actually came
from government-funded projects
at the behest of Anthony Fauci.
- Are you ever sympathetic
to the arguments that
if we don't do these
things, gain of function,
as potentially dangerous
as it might be,
and sort of leaping
these viruses
into new territory, that
if we don't do it, well,
the Chinese are
still gonna do it,
other bad countries
are still gonna do it,
and we'll still end up here,
but we'll just sort of
be behind the eight ball
when it comes to
dealing with them.
Does that vibe with you at all?
- There's a real
scientific debate over
whether there's any value
to these experiments.
Think about the experiments
we're talking about.
So Ebola has a 50% mortality.
It comes out of Africa
most of the time.
It's spread through
bodily fluids like AIDS,
so it's not contagious through
the air and that's fortunate.
It's not as contagious
as it could be.
Would it be worthwhile to
do an experiment to see
if we could make
Ebola aerosolized
if we could allow, or AIDS,
or some kind of disease,
would it be worth
it to try to create
a disease and make
it aerosolized?
Well, is there some
kind of knowledge you
could get for that?
Maybe, but it could also escape
and infect the whole world.
So, I mean, no,
it's a death wish,
and there are many, many,
many career scientists,
even the virologists who worked
with Fauci on the papers
to justify what happened,
many of them in private
have said they don't see
the importance or the
benefit of gain of function,
and then some people say it's
not worth it at all, and so,
but it takes a refined look
at what the definition is
because the other side will say,
"Oh, you don't
wanna allow bacteria
to create insulin, you know,
where we make a bacteria
so it can produce insulin."
That's not true at all.
What we don't want is to monkey
around with things
that can be aerosolized
and we don't wanna
genetically create them
to be more transmissible
or more lethal.
- So the title "Deception," I
think also was the right word
because so many
people were deceived
by these people and
continue to be deceived.
I keep saying, you know,
when they come back
with the next thing,
whether it's the next COVID
or it's climate
lockdowns or whatever,
we're gonna be
really disappointed
with the amount of people
who will be deceived again.
What would be your
message to the people
when whatever the next thing is,
quote, unquote, thing, to
not fall for, you know,
these mid-level
management people
and the bureaucracies and the
institutions and all of that?
- Well, it's actually
how I became intrigued
in this book and in
the subject, period.
When I read the Freedom
of Information Act,
a judge ordered the
release of emails
of Fauci and these
virologists on January 31st.
So about 10:30 at night, Fauci
begins exchanging emails.
He exchanges them till
three in the morning.
You can tell by the
tenor that he's worried
and he's concerned, not
only about the origins,
but that the origins
could boomerang
and come back and that
he could be exposed
as the one who
approved the funding.
He also said-
- And to be clear, you're
talking about January of 2020?
- Of 2020.
- Yeah.
- At 3AM, he sends an email
to somebody who's in charge of
the committee that's supposed
to review dangerous research.
So this discussion had been
going on for years before this.
They had actually had a pause,
they had stopped all
funding for this research,
and then they
created a committee
that was a safety committee,
it was called the
P3 CO Committee.
Well, it turns out the head
of that committee, Fauci,
is emailing him at
three in the morning
the first night he
becomes alarmed saying,
"Nothing to see here.
We think this probably
came from nature,"
but what wasn't explicit,
and I didn't learn until I got
into this book and developed it,
is that the research
was never reviewed
by the safety committee.
Fauci gave them an
exemption and went around,
and when I challenged Fauci
on this committee, I said,
"This is gain of function."
He says, "All my experts
have said up and down,
12 experts told me, this
is not gain of function,"
but if that happened,
let's see the paperwork,
let's see the discussion,
let's see the debate over this,
because we know for one thing,
Fauci allowed this research
to happen in Communist China
without any review by
the safety committee.
That alone is malfeasance and he
should be punished
for it as well.
- What would reforming these
institutions look like?
You know, everyone
says, okay, fine,
or everyone, let's say, on
our side, basically says,
we have to reform these
things or blow them apart
or whatever, the CDC,
NIH, et cetera, et cetera.
What would it actually look like
if you had the power to do that?
- Well, we have a group of 33
scientists who have written
an open letter to Congress
and to the public on this,
and they have come up
with a series of ideas,
and we actually go
through this in the book,
what would the
bipartisan-type reform be?
That shouldn't be controversial.
One, they say that the
people funding this research
should not be the same
people receiving the money.
You need to separate
the people analyzing
this from the
people receiving it.
So one of the big problems
is that Fauci's inner circle,
the guy who writes the paper
that says everybody's a kook
and a conspiracy
theorist that believes
this came from a lab in China,
he got an $8,000,000
grant in the middle
of all this that had to
be approved by Fauci,
and these are all
scientists who,
in private emails, are all
saying, "Holy you know what!
This looks like it
came out of a lab!
It looks like it
was manipulated,"
and, this is in Fauci's words,
"We know they were doing gain
of function research in Wuhan,"
which is exactly the opposite of
what he told me in committee!
He says,
"We are not funding this.
- Right.
- "We are not-"
- We played the clip, yeah.
- Gain of function
in Wuhan, and yet,
in private, in 2020,
a year before I interviewed him,
he's admitting privately
that he's very worried
that this came from the lab
because he knows
they're doing gain
of function research
in that lab.
So there's never been so much,
I don't think there's
ever been a coverup
so thoroughly exposed and caught
and delivered by their
own emails, and yet,
not one person from
the mainstream media
has reported on this at all.
They still have him.
He still gets $1,000,000 prizes
from these left-wing
foundations.
He's still being paid.
You know he still works
for the government.
He still has-
- Right.
- A full security detail!
We've been asking questions.
He said he retired. How
come he still has a detail?
Are they gonna
defend him legally
if he is indicted by the House?
So there are all
kinds of questions,
but there's been
virtually no interest
from the mainstream
media on this.
- Can you at least
get his pension cut?
Isn't he still getting
400 grand a year?
Could you at least,
is there somebody you could talk
to at least on that, I mean,
throw us a bone here?
- We have a hard time even
finding out what his pension is
much less getting
his pension cut.
His security detail
they've been hiding
under a rock and passing
the rock around government.
HHS, which is oversees NIH
Health and Human Services,
has hidden the grants and
the non-classified documents
more than the CIA on this.
We get 250-page
tranches of pages
that are completely blacked
out, completely redacted,
and they're not classified.
We voted unanimously
in the Senate
and the House to
declassify all of this.
Senate to Biden's
desk, unanimous in
both House and Senate,
and still we get no information.
We are fighting
them tooth and nail.
I have to basically use leverage
to get a Democrat to sign
any letter asking
for information.
They'll do one letter
with this much information
and then we don't get
it for three months
and then we get another
letter only if we extort them
by blocking nominations or
blocking their legislation.
- I think I know the
answer to this, but I mean,
does it blow your
mind in any way
how partisan this has become,
the fact that you'd think that
now, knowing what we know,
more people on the other side
would wanna help you with this,
but I'm pretty sure
you're getting stonewalled
at every turn.
- Yeah, I'm amazed by it,
that no Democrat
has stepped forward,
that 1,000,000 people die.
Look, these are the
same Democrats who think
that the plastic in your bottles
and your glasses
is causing cancer.
- Right.
- We've had 10 hearings
on the plastic in glasses and
in baby's bottles
causing cancer, which
it probably doesn't,
but we've had 10 hearings on it.
We haven't had one hearing
on the origins of the virus.
I had one in a subcommittee
and the Democrats boycotted it.
I spent two years trying
to get one subcommittee
hearing and now,
I'm the ranking member
of an entire committee,
meaning I'm in the minority
and I don't get to
control the agenda.
We've had no hearings
on the origins of COVID.
- Would you say
that the best way
for people to inoculate
themselves from,
again, whatever
the next thing is,
would be to just live in a state
that's gonna offer
them those protections?
Obviously, you know
I'm here in Florida
where we've done
a lot to make sure
that, you know, next
time it comes back,
you're not gonna be forced to
be locked down or
mandated anything,
I think you've done some things
in Kentucky, but basically,
we're just gonna see
this red-blue divide
on this and it'll-
- Yep.
- Just increasingly go that way.
- This is the beauty
of the state system,
or the federalist system,
where power is supposed to
be devolved to the states,
and I do think
that Republican governors
did learn from this.
Some of them did initially
participate in lockdowns
and I think they
thought better of it.
In my state, we have
a Democrat governor,
and he ruled by emergency edict,
and almost every
one of his edicts,
I think everyone was
eventually struck
down by courts, but eventually,
our state legislature came back
in power and we've now said
that you can't have an
emergency last longer
than 30 days unless
approved by the legislature.
We should do that
in Washington too.
There are rules on the
books that allow a president
in an emergency to
shut off the internet,
to close all communications
in the country.
It's been there
since the thirties.
Now, it doesn't
say the internet,
it says all communications,
but it's interpreted-
- [Dave] Right.
- It's been interpreted
now as being
a so-called internet
kill switch.
It's just been on the books.
I think we should get rid
of all of those emergencies.
I can't think of any
law or any emergency
where the legislature
shouldn't act,
and if you need something in
an emergency like blankets
or water after a tornado,
those are the only emergency
powers we should have.
We should never close
restaurants, schools,
and everything else based on
one person's opinion or edict,
'cause it turns out the science
wasn't very good on this.
The masks, 78 randomized
controlled studies,
the meta-analysis
of all that shows
the mask didn't
prevent transmission.
The vaccine doesn't
prevent transmission,
may help you if you're
in a targeted group
that's at high risk for this,
but is of no value really for
children, and interestingly,
the committees at the FDA,
the vaccine committee,
and the CDC, the
vaccine committee,
actually voted against giving
the third vaccine to children.
It was overruled by
a political appointee
in the Biden administration.
All of the scientists
agreed to only give it
to people over 65
as a recommendation,
but once it becomes part of
this dogma, it gets fed down,
and even the states
that don't want this
may be forced to put it
into the school system
'cause the school system says,
"Oh, we're going with best
practices from the CDC,"
but I can tell you,
there is no good science to say
that your child should
get a COVID vaccine, zero.
If your kid's already had COVID,
they don't need a vaccine.
Even if your kid
hadn't had COVID,
they probably have anyway
and you just didn't know it,
but kids don't need a vaccine
for a non-deadly disease,
and the complications from
the vaccine aren't extremely
common, they're fairly rare,
about one or two out of 15,000,
but do you wanna take that
chance and roll the dice
with your perfectly healthy kid
that survives COVID like a cold?
No, there's no reason
to take any chances
with your children
on a COVID vaccine.
- I can tell you, as a
relatively new father, I mean,
the idea that they're
recommending six month olds get
this stuff, it seems
so profoundly insane,
but let let me just
ask you one more
'cause I know you got a couple
things to do over there,
the business of the government
even though sometimes
it's a little slow.
What do you think the
next thing will be?
You know, a lot of people
sort of think, okay,
they'll just have
another COVID situation
before an election, or it
could be climate-related,
or they'll scare us with
this Russia, Ukraine thing.
I mean, do you sense
that there are just,
we'll just be in this time
of, every couple of years,
they will gin up something?
- Some have come to me from
the public health sphere,
people who have PhDs in virology
and are intimately
involved with this,
and they believe
that there will be
another pandemic
in our lifetime,
really within a few years.
Their fear is that the next one
could have a mortality
between five and 50%.
So this one, as bad
as it was, was 0.3.
The normal (indistinct)
is about 0.1.
That's about 1,000,000
people in the US.
0.3 is about 3,000,000, no,
0.3 is about
1,000,000 in the US,
so 0.1 is about
300,000 or so, but 50%?
Now, we're talking about
180,000,000 people dying.
50% of the planet dying,
we're talking about maybe worse
than the Black Plague,
you know, bubonic plague.
We're talking about
something so devastating
that it can put
civilization back thousands
of years as the people
who can fix stuff
and create stuff and make things
and invent things and teachers,
all these people are
wiped out at 50%.
This could happen. This
is how big a deal this is.
There's an MIT scientist
who is by no means,
you know, a flat earther.
He does CRISPR technology.
He's an amazing
scientist, Kevin Esvelt,
and he wrote in the
Washington Post,
and I have no idea
what his politics are,
but he wrote in
the Washington Post
that the next time this happens,
or what could happen from
gain of function research,
is basically a gamble and a risk
that civilization
shouldn't encounter.
This is an issue as big or
bigger than nuclear war and it
should be treated with the
same gravity and seriousness,
and it is bizarre to
me that the Left's love
of Anthony Fauci
has forbidden them
from even looking at the issue.
- Well, Senator, that's
exactly why everyone
should check out the book,
we will link to "Deception"
right down below,
and I thank you for your
time and as I always say,
being on the short
list of politicians
that I can say
are actually sane,
so thank you, Senator Rand Paul.
- Thanks, Dave.
Thanks for having me.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.